JANET KUO: Hi.
I'm Janet Kuo, software
engineer at Google
and also co-chair of KubeCon.
Today, I did a keynote on
Kubernetes project update,
and I'd like to give
you a recap on it.
So I had a Kubernetes look back,
and a history of Kubernetes,
starting from Google created
Borg, and then the Linux
containers, and then
the Docker containers,
and then Omega projects.
And then we open sourced
Kubernetes, and until this day,
Kubernetes has
become very popular,
and we have over
31,000 contributors.
And it's also one of the highest
velocity projects on GitHub.
Today, Kubernetes is
very stable and mature,
and we are celebrating
the five-years anniversary
for Kubernetes.
And the next focus
in the community
will be on extensibility.
I expect more people to
extend on top of Kubernets.
And then scalability--
I expect we
keep improving the scalability
limits on Kubernetes.
And the third focus will
be around reliability.
We need to fix the cascading
failures more holistically,
and we need to do it
together, as a community.
I expect you to
contribute to Kubernetes.
And if you have questions,
feel free to meet us
at Google's booth.
Thank you.